toaster pastries I mean do you toast
them or you just see them like that
never toaster pastry in my life it looks
like bread jam with icing it's a proud
sponsor of the American Olympics I
cannot see Michael Phelps winning gold
medals eating this word this is the
cause for obesity in America that is so
sweet
this is what I've been waiting for
really taste the explosion what is gonna
blast in my mouth I love how they sound
out what do you want to eat them you're
making hair washing powder I mean the
only thing I've seen is breaking bad but
this seriously looks like method 1 2 3
go
whoa oh my god wow that's like the
valley in my mouth who's gonna taste
like toothpaste a bit
my mouth is having a battle with itself
and there's just like Rockets flying all
over I wish I could sound like this
although I really can't make out any
flavor but I'm just enjoying the
experience of stuff popping in my mouth
yeah okay I do like this this is this is
awesome the explosion was good
Twinkies what kind of name is Twinkies I
heard about the song Zombieland
individually-wrapped cakes that makes me
feel important for sleep
looks very creamy that's a lot of cream
that is a lot of cream
okay this is now a cake maava cake is
like Twinkies but better made by local
bakeries in India good nah I like it man
nice but very sweet I thought it'd be
horrible and like would be really heavy
and dense and disgusting
those damn tasty things I need to brush
my teeth Butterfinger crispity crunchity
peanut buttery
oh wow I didn't expect it to be you're
so hard inside really crunchy crispy and
crunchy good it tastes like jerky
yeah I thought it would be like a five
star which you
in India this is just totally different
when you bite into it and I would
definitely have this over most Indian
chocolate I'm really excited about this
because I love Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory as a kid this is like play-doh
boy is really chewy this is gonna take a
while it really feels like everything
clear he's gonna probably take me the
entire cricket match to eat the candy is
like send us off like I'm getting this
like really sour taste but it's also a
nice sour dish thumbs up American
processed foods oh oh wait I think one
of the earlier pop rocks just popped
again do you guys have this every day
yeah because if you guys have this every
day I heard you can't imagine like how
your lifestyle must be right I'm just
imagining a bunch of hype really
hyperactive kids man what I really like
though was was those pop rocks which
were really I mean they just blew my
mind
apart from my mouth